when we humans look at the universe
around us we're blown away by the
complexity and the diversity of
all the things we see from the scale of
things in the cosmos like stars this is
a picture of our sun
all the way down to a more human scale
and all the way down to the microscopic
scale this is a visualization of a
coronavirus
it seems like there's an infinite number
of things out there
but an interesting question has always
been are there some
basic building blocks things a smaller
set a finite set of things that we can
put together
to make up all of this complexity
ancients
thought about maybe it's fire water wind
but now we know that there are things
called
elements and we have classified them on
the periodic
table of elements and we know today of
about 118
elements but we might discover more but
what's mind-blowing is
all matter that we know of in the
universe is made up of combinations
of these elements now what's even more
amazing is
most of what we experience in our
everyday lives is made up of an even
smaller subset of these elements for
example almost
99 of the mass on earth
is made up of these eight elements
and if we look at ourselves if you were
to stare at your hand or look in the
mirror
life as we know it is made up of
mainly these six elements hydrogen
carbon nitrogen
oxygen phosphorus and sulfur now the
earth
and life is made up of other elements
but it is amazing
how much complexity and how much can be
made with combinations
of the things that we see in the
periodic table of elements
now the next question is all right we
can make things
out of these elements but what if we
were to keep cutting an element or what
if we were to keep cutting a substance
down
what is the smallest unit that still
maintains the properties of an element
and that unit you have probably heard
the word is
known as an atom
and atoms can be further broken down in
fact an atom has a nucleus
and inside that nucleus it has subatomic
particles
known as protons and
neutrons in that nucleus and then you
can imagine
buzzing around and we're talking about
very very small scale and it's hard to
pinpoint
it's more of a probability where you
might find these but buzzing around
that nucleus you have electrons and the
protons
have a positive charge the neutrons have
a neutral charge
and the electrons have a negative charge
but everything we're talking about is
made up of combinations of these three
fundamental particles and what's
especially cool
is a given atom is mostly free space
you have the dense nucleus but then
these atoms are just
buzzing around when mostly free space
and what actually gives an atom the
properties of a specific
element is the number of protons we're
dealing with
so for example what makes an atom a
hydrogen is it has
one proton what makes an atom a chlorine
is that it has 17 protons the number of
electrons can change that will change
its
charge and that might change how it
interacts with other atoms
but it still will be classified as a
for example carbon regardless of how
many electrons it has
and similarly the number of neutrons
don't affect its charge but it will
affect the mass
that we're dealing with but even if you
change the number of neutrons you're
still
and you have the same number of protons
you're still dealing
if you say you have six protons no
matter how many neutrons or electrons
you have you're still dealing with
carbon
it's really interesting to appreciate
just how
small atoms are if you think about it
just as a number the width of let's say
a carbon atom and there are smaller
atoms like a hydrogen atom or a helium
atom
but the width of a carbon atom is
roughly 1 times 10
to the negative 10 meters another way to
think about it
and it depends on the context you're
seeing the carbon but roughly speaking
if you took 10 billion carbons and put
them side by side it would be about a
meter wide
or if you want to blow your mind even
further if you had about 10 million
carbons and put them side by side
that would be about a millimeter so try
to approximate a millimeter a millimeter
depending on the resolution on your
screen
might be something like that there would
be 10
million carbons depending on how big
you're looking at this video
just in that space over there if that
doesn't blow your mind enough
another way to think about it is it's
estimated that there are more
atoms in a grain of sand than there are
grains of sand
in all of the beaches on earth
and if that doesn't blow your mind
roughly speaking
if you took an apple and if you made the
apple
the size of the earth then
an atom in that apple would be the size
of an apple you could you can hear that
again and process that if you took
or another way to think about an atom of
an apple is to the apple as an apple
is to all of earth so
atoms are tiny tiny tiny
so i'm going to leave you there that's
enough mind blowing for one video
and then in future videos we'll discuss
more in depth about
atoms and the subatomic particles that
make them up
and we'll talk more about classifying
the different types of matter